This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Say the words fairy tale and a pleasant vision comes to mind. Beautiful princesses, charming dwarves, and adorable animals. But in their original incarnation, fairy tales were a lot grislier than the sunny stories we tell today. Grimm's fairy tales, first published in Germany in 1812, included stories like the robber bridegroom. It told of a young woman,
这里是Hidden Brain。我是Shankar Vedantam。提到“童话”这个词，人们脑海中会浮现出一幅美好的画面：美丽的公主、迷人的矮人，还有可爱的动物。但在最初的版本中，童话故事比我们今天讲述的那些阳光明媚的故事要残酷得多。《格林童话》于1812年首次在德国出版，其中就包括像《强盗新郎》这样的故事。它讲述了一位年轻女子，
who visits the home of the man to whom she is engaged, only to discover that he is the leader of a band of cannibalistic robbers. She hides and watches as the robbers murder another young woman, cut her up, and eat her. She exposes the robbers by giving the authorities a victim-severed finger, which has a ring on it. In another tale, called the juniper tree, a stepmother kills her stepson,
去拜访她未婚夫的家，却发现他是食人强盗团伙的首领。她躲起来看着强盗们谋杀另一位年轻女子，将她肢解并吃掉。她通过向当局提供受害者的一根断指（上面戴着戒指）来揭发这些强盗。在另一个名为《杜松子树》的故事中，继母杀死了继子，
chops him up and serves him in a stew to his unsuspecting father. His sister collects the boy's bones and buries them under a juniper tree. The boy is reborn as a bird who kills the stepmom by dropping a stone on her head. Even Snow White, the sweet story we know from the Disney version, was far scarier in original form. The evil queen, jealous of her beautiful stepdaughter Snow White, try several times to kill the girl. After the evil queen is caught, she is forced to wear red-hot iron shoes
把他剁碎做成炖菜，端给了毫不知情的父亲。他的妹妹收集了男孩的骨头，把它们埋在杜松子树下。男孩重生为一只鸟，通过向继母头上扔石头杀死了她。即使是我们从迪士尼版本中熟知的甜蜜故事《白雪公主》，在原始版本中也可怕得多。邪恶的王后嫉妒美丽的继女白雪公主，多次试图杀死她。邪恶王后被抓住后，被迫穿上烧红的铁鞋，
and dance until she dies. Today, these collections of gruesome and ghastly tales are often presented to children in highly sanitized form. As parents and teachers, many of us are worried about causing irreparable psychic harm. But what does that say about earlier generations of caregivers who happily read these stories to their kids. Did they care less about the well-being of their offspring?
跳舞直到死去。如今，这些令人毛骨悚然、恐怖至极的故事集通常以高度删减的形式呈现给孩子们。作为父母和老师，我们许多人担心这会造成不可挽回的心理伤害。但这对那些乐于给孩子读这些故事的早期照顾者们又意味着什么呢？难道他们就不关心后代的福祉吗？
Historical accounts do not suggest these stories traumatized children in the past. Indeed, the enduring popularity of grisly stories, sometimes over centuries, suggests there was robust appetite for such tales. So, what changed? Today we take a deep dive, not into the world of children's fairy tales, but the larger question of how how we think human beings respond to accounts and experiences of tragedy and how they actually respond. Grief, trauma, and resilience this week on Hidden Brain. I grew up in India, where traffic accidents and deaths were commonplace. I personally know multiple friends and family members who died in traffic crashes.
历史记录并不表明这些故事在过去给孩子们造成了创伤。事实上，这些恐怖故事长盛不衰的流行（有时跨越几个世纪）表明，人们对这类故事有着强烈的需求。那么，是什么改变了呢？今天，我们不深入探讨儿童童话的世界，而是探讨一个更大的问题：我们认为人类如何应对悲剧的叙述和经历，以及他们实际上是如何应对的。本周的Hidden Brain将探讨悲伤、创伤和韧性。我在印度长大，那里的交通事故和死亡司空见惯。我个人就认识多位在车祸中丧生的朋友和家人。
When I first came to the United States, I was surprised that people talked a lot more about traffic safety, even though the roads were much safer. In time, I came to realize that the very ubiquity of traffic fatalities in India made people more blazee. Things that happen every day fade into the background. airplane crashes, which are rare, draw intense attention. The same thing happens to cultures over time. Things that were surprising in one day and age become commonplace in another. And things that are seen as commonplace in one day and age
当我第一次来到美国时，我很惊讶人们谈论交通安全要多得多，尽管这里的道路要安全得多。久而久之，我意识到印度交通死亡事故的普遍性反而让人们变得麻木。每天发生的事情会逐渐淡出人们的视野。飞机失事虽然罕见，却能引起极大的关注。随着时间的推移，文化也会发生同样的事情。在某个时代令人惊讶的事情，在另一个时代却变得司空见惯。而在某个时代被视为司空见惯的事情，
can come to be seen as shocking. At Columbia University, psychologist George Bonana, who has studied how many cultures today have come to think about suffering and grief and tragedy very differently than people did in the past. Bonano, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much, Shankar. I'm very happy to be with you to talk with you. George, I'm wondering if I could start with a personal story. You grew up in Chicago.
在另一个时代却可能被视为令人震惊。在哥伦比亚大学，心理学家George Bonano研究了当今许多文化是如何以与过去完全不同的方式看待苦难、悲伤和悲剧的。Bonano，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。非常感谢，Shankar。很高兴能和你一起交流。George，我想从一个个人故事开始。你在芝加哥长大。
How would you describe your relationship with your dad? I would say it was a very complicated and fraught relationship. The neighborhood I grew up in was a Sicilian neighborhood, Sicilian immigrants, and it was a tough neighborhood. My father would beat us at times. The beatings were not as bad as the anger that he exhibited. He would go into these rages, and he was a very scary human being then. I understand that he himself was someone who took on a lot as he went through his life. And in some ways, you saw that, and perhaps alone among your siblings, you actually empathized with what he was going through. Can you describe what that was like, George? Yeah, my father worked very, very hard, and I think was becoming depressed. He'd also had
你会如何描述你和你父亲的关系？我会说那是一种非常复杂且充满矛盾的关系。我长大的社区是一个西西里社区，住着西西里移民，那是一个艰难的社区。我父亲有时会打我们。殴打本身并不如他表现出的愤怒那么糟糕。他会陷入那种狂怒中，那时他是一个非常可怕的人。我理解他自己一生中也承受了很多。在某种程度上，你看到了这一点，也许在你所有的兄弟姐妹中，你是唯一真正同情他所经历的一切的人。你能描述一下那是什么感觉吗，George？是的，我父亲工作非常非常努力，我想他当时正变得抑郁。他还有
serious health problems. He'd had several heart attacks. He's been. becoming diabetic. So his life was kind of slipping away from him. And I would catch him at times lying in the dark in bed. And I would go in and talk with him. And he would say to me basically, you know, don't, don't try to talk with me. And so I think there was a kind of a sense that he gave up what he wanted to do or he gave up the sense of he could have done other things in life. So this all came to a head when I finished high school, barely finished high school, and then I left home.
严重的健康问题。他心脏病发作过几次。他患上了糖尿病。所以他的生命正在一点点从他手中溜走。有时我会发现他躺在黑暗的床上。我会进去和他说话。他基本上会对我讲，你知道，别，别试图跟我说话。所以我认为他有一种感觉，他放弃了他想做的事情，或者他放弃了那种他本可以在生活中做其他事情的感觉。这一切在我高中毕业时达到了顶峰，我勉强高中毕业，然后就离家出走了。
And my father had said quite infamously in my mind, if you leave now, don't come crawling back. And that, you know, was emblazoned on my mind after that. So you did end up leaving at the age of 17. You traveled widely, including to other countries. Sometimes you slept outside. When you were 23, you found yourself in Colorado, and you got a call in the middle of the night. I understand that initially you decided to ignore the ringing phone.
我父亲当时说了一句在我心中非常出名的话：如果你现在离开，就别再爬着回来。那句话，你知道，在那之后就烙印在我的脑海里了。所以你最终在17岁时离开了。你游历广泛，包括去过其他国家。有时你睡在外面。当你23岁时，你发现自己在科罗拉多州，半夜接到一个电话。我理解你最初决定忽略那个响着的电话。
Well, the phone rang repeatedly, and I was with somebody. I was with a woman that I was very interested in. And I didn't answer the phone. After several repeats of this ringing, I decided there was some. something very much important. Got up, answered the phone, and it was my older brother telling me that my father had died. What went through your mind in the hours and days that followed, George? Well, we were beginning actually to move towards some sort of reconciliation. I don't think
嗯，电话响个不停，当时我和某个人在一起。我和一位我非常感兴趣的女士在一起。我没有接电话。在电话响了几次之后，我决定一定有什么非常重要的事情。我起身接了电话，是我哥哥打来的，告诉我父亲去世了。在接下来的几个小时和几天里，你的脑海里在想什么，George？嗯，我们其实正开始走向某种和解。我不认为
that was likely to happen, but we were kind of somehow trying to find each other a little bit. And I was not sure at that point I had not experienced this kind of death before. And I was wondering what would I experience. And what I experienced was essentially silence. It was in the wintertime. Everything was more or less frozen and covered snow. And I walked out, went for a long walk, and everything was slow and silent and peaceful. The silence somehow seemed, it wasn't what I expected, but it seemed like a natural process. It was George's first real experience dealing with death. He expected he would have tears, but none appeared.
那很可能会发生，但我们当时正试图以某种方式重新了解彼此。在那一刻，我不确定，因为我之前没有经历过这种死亡。我想知道我会经历什么。而我所经历的本质上是沉默。那是冬天。一切都或多或少被冰冻并覆盖着积雪。我走出去，去散了很长一段步，一切都是缓慢、安静且平和的。这种沉默不知何故似乎……这不是我所预期的，但它看起来像是一个自然的过程。这是George第一次真正处理死亡的经历。他以为自己会流泪，但什么也没发生。
People moved hesitantly around him, as if they were worried he would splinter into tiny shards if they said the wrong thing. This, too, felt strange. George felt grateful that his father's pain was over. He felt relief. In time, he became a researcher who studied how people respond to losses and setbacks. Over and over, he saw examples of people who did not follow the conventional script. One was a college student whom George calls Julia.
人们在他身边犹豫地走动，好像担心如果他们说错了话，他会碎成碎片。这也让他感到奇怪。George很感激父亲的痛苦结束了。他感到解脱。久而久之，他成为了一名研究人们如何应对损失和挫折的研究员。他一次又一次地看到人们不遵循传统剧本的例子。其中一位是George称之为Julia的大学生。
Julia was home from college, and she was at her family's home. She was preparing dinner with her mother, and the phone rang, and she heard her mother cry out in anguish. And the news was that the father had been bicycling home from work and was hit by a car, and he was in the ICU, the intensive care unit. Julian and her mother drove to the hospital, and just as they arrived, he died. Julia reports that she was absolutely stunned, and she remembers crying a lot, but everything else is kind of a blur. She fell into this state where she was very upset, was having difficulty sleeping, etc. So after the initial shock of her father's death, Julia went back to school, plunged into
Julia大学放假回家，在家里。她正和母亲准备晚餐，电话响了，她听到母亲痛苦地大叫。消息是父亲在骑自行车下班回家的路上被车撞了，正在ICU（重症监护室）。Julia和母亲开车赶到医院，就在她们到达时，他去世了。Julia说她当时完全惊呆了，她记得哭得很厉害，但其他一切都变得模糊不清。她陷入了一种非常难过的状态，睡眠困难等等。所以，在父亲去世的最初冲击之后，Julia回到了学校，投入到
her schoolwork. When friends asked her if she wanted to talk about her father's death, how did she? she respond? For the most part, she did not want to talk about her father's death. She wanted to simply be with her friends as friends, as companions. And she really didn't want to think about it to dwell on it. She'd already suffered some before she went back to school. And I think now she was very clearly focused on simply doing what she was doing there, engaging in that work and not dwelling on it. She, I think, did well. And then she came home quite excited because she got an internship at a newspaper. She was excited to be doing that.
她的学业中。当朋友们问她是否想谈谈父亲的去世时，她是如何回应的？在大多数情况下，她不想谈论父亲的去世。她只想简单地和朋友们在一起，作为朋友，作为伙伴。她真的不想去想它，不想沉溺于其中。她在回学校之前已经经历了一些痛苦。我想现在她非常专注于简单地做她正在做的事情，投入到工作中，而不是沉溺于悲伤。我想她做得很好。后来她回家时非常兴奋，因为她得到了一份报社的实习工作。她为能做那份工作感到兴奋。
I understand that Julia's mother had some firm ideas about how Julia ought to be responding to her father's death. How did her mother respond, George? Well, her mother was quite worried that Julia seemed to have forgotten her father. She was acting essentially as if life had returned to normal, and her mother worried that she had denied her grief. This was the phrase that Julia used, that she denied her grief, and suggested that she, Julia, see a grief counselor to get at the bottom of it. And did she? She did, and it was interesting because the counselor asked her a lot of questions about a relationship with her father.
我理解Julia的母亲对Julia应该如何应对父亲的去世有一些固定的想法。她的母亲是如何反应的，George？嗯，她的母亲非常担心Julia似乎已经忘记了父亲。她的表现基本上就像生活已经恢复正常一样，她的母亲担心她否认了自己的悲伤。这就是Julia使用的短语，说她“否认了自己的悲伤”，并建议Julia去看悲伤咨询师，以查明真相。她去了吗？她去了，这很有趣，因为咨询师问了她很多关于她和父亲关系的问题。
And Julia said something to the effect of, I'm not stupid, I could see what he was aiming at. She was not happy about this, but she played along with it for a period. And then I think what happened was, if I remember correctly, the number of sessions that would be covered, perhaps by insurance, had run out. And it was a sort of a natural ending point. And her mother agreed. She said, I don't want to do this anymore. And her mother agreed that she could stop.
Julia说了一些类似“我不傻，我能看出他在打什么主意”的话。她对此并不高兴，但她还是配合了一段时间。然后我想发生的事情是，如果我没记错的话，保险覆盖的咨询次数用完了。这是一个自然的结束点。她的母亲同意了。她说，我不想再这样做了。她的母亲同意她可以停止。
I mean, it's striking, George, that Julia's mother felt she had to go to therapy, not because Julia's grief was destabilizing her, but because she wasn't in her mother's eyes experiencing enough grief. Yes. It's a very common assumption that grief is something we need to do and that it's painful. It has to be painful. That's the assumption. Another person you encountered was a young man you called Jed. He had been working in New York City as an aspiring musician when he suffered a terrible accident one night. What happened to him, George? Jed was working at an upscale restaurant in the West Greenwich Village. It was about 1.30 in the morning on December 21st.
我的意思是，George，令人震惊的是，Julia的母亲觉得她必须去接受治疗，不是因为Julia的悲伤让她变得不稳定，而是因为在母亲眼中，她经历的悲伤不够多。是的。这是一个非常普遍的假设，即悲伤是我们必须经历的事情，而且它必须是痛苦的。这就是假设。你遇到的另一个人是一个你称之为Jed的年轻人。他曾在纽约市做一名有抱负的音乐家，一天晚上遭遇了一场可怕的事故。他发生了什么事，George？Jed当时在西格林威治村的一家高档餐厅工作。那是12月21日凌晨1点30分左右。
It was very cold, about 20 degrees Fahrenheit. And he walked to the corner. He remembers seeing the walk signal shimmering off the frozen pavement. So he walked into the intersection and a garbage truck, a sanitation truck, made an illegal right turn very fast and clipped him and pulled him under the truck. It ran over his left leg and hip and just crushed it to a massive blood and bone. It was horrific accident. I'm assuming he must have been rushed to the hospital immediately. Not immediately, unfortunately.
天气非常冷，大约20华氏度（约零下6摄氏度）。他走到街角。他记得看到人行横道信号灯在冰冻的路面上闪烁。于是他走进十字路口，一辆垃圾车，一辆环卫车，违规快速右转，撞倒了他并把他卷到了车下。它碾过了他的左腿和臀部，把他压成了一团血肉模糊的骨头。那是一场可怕的事故。我假设他一定被立即送往医院了。不幸的是，并没有立即送医。
So the emergency responders came. He recalls this all vividly because he was awake for the whole thing. He was screaming wildly. The police arrived, the firefighters arrived. He remembers that the ambulance was delayed. I believe he thought it was delayed in traffic. At 1.30 in the morning, that's possible. in New York. He remembers hearing the first responders yelling, put a rush on the bus, which is
急救人员赶到了。他对此记忆犹新，因为他全程都是清醒的。他疯狂地尖叫。警察到了，消防员到了。他记得救护车延误了。我相信他认为是因为交通堵塞而延误了。在凌晨1点30分，在纽约这是有可能的。他记得听到急救人员大喊“快点叫救护车”，这是
first responders speak for get the ambulance here. And they told him afterwards that if it wasn't so cold, he probably would have bled out and died because he was bleeding so profusely. But the cold weather slowed the flow of blood. And then eventually the ambulance came and they got him to the hospital. What happened there? They put him into a coma and kept him into a medical induced coma for six weeks. I believe he had 20 surgeries, if I'm remembering the number correctly, and he'd also experienced a number of infections. And they kind of rebuilt his body to function without so much of it. About a quarter of his body was lost in this accident. Did he end up losing the leg? He lost the entire leg and part of his hip. So he's a handsome man. And when you see
急救人员的行话，意思是让救护车赶快过来。他们后来告诉他，如果不是天气那么冷，他可能早就失血过多死亡了，因为他流血太多了。但寒冷的天气减缓了血液流动。最终救护车来了，他们把他送到了医院。那里发生了什么？他们让他陷入昏迷，并让他保持了六周的医学诱导昏迷。如果我没记错数字的话，我相信他做了20次手术，而且他还经历了几次感染。他们算是重塑了他的身体，让他在失去这么多部分的情况下还能运作。他在这次事故中失去了大约四分之一的身体。他最终失去那条腿了吗？他失去了整条腿和部分臀部。所以他是一个英俊的男人。当你看到
him on the street, people sometimes do double takes because so much of him is gone. You know, at first, it seems not possible that so much of a person could be gone. And, yeah, so he gets around quite well on different kinds of equipment crutches and such. But, yeah, a lot of him is gone. So describe for me what happened in the days and weeks that followed this horrific accident and his recovery in the hospital. I mean, he comes out of this, but he's clearly mangled in some ways. Yeah. What happens to him mentally, psychically?
他在街上时，人们有时会回头看，因为他失去的部分太多了。你知道，起初，似乎一个人失去这么多部分是不可能的。而且，是的，他用各种设备，拐杖之类的，走动得相当好。但是，是的，他失去了很多。所以请为我描述一下在这场可怕的事故后的几天和几周里，以及他在医院康复期间发生了什么。我的意思是，他从这次事故中活了下来，但他显然在某些方面残缺不全了。是的。他在精神上、心理上发生了什么？
Well, his family was first very worried at how he would react when he woke up and found so much of him was gone. You know, he woke up with tubes coming out of him and a chunk of his body missing. But he said that he already knew. It's somehow gotten into his consciousness through sleep or how. It's not clear how, but he already knew. But then he began to have these just vividly intense memories of the entire accident. because, as I mentioned, he was fully conscious for this accident. So he was replaying all of these memories for several days.
嗯，他的家人起初非常担心他醒来发现自己失去了这么多部分时会作何反应。你知道，他醒来时身上插着管子，身体缺失了一大块。但他却说他已经知道了。不知何故，这通过睡眠或其他方式进入了他的意识。不清楚是怎么回事，但他已经知道了。但随后他开始对整个事故产生极其生动的强烈记忆，因为正如我提到的，他在整个事故过程中完全清醒。所以他连续几天都在重播所有这些记忆。
And then, to his surprise, and I think to maybe everybody's surprise, it more or less just stopped. It took about a week. And then all of these intrusive memories and intense replaying of the accident simply just stopped. And he was confused by that. In some ways, his confusion seems to refurb. the same concerns that Julia's mother had. In other words, Jed was doing relatively well, but he found himself asking why he was not doing worse? Yes. He was wondering his exact words, why was I doing okay? And he said, this is really my question. Why was I doing okay? He'd already
然后，令他惊讶的是，我想也许令所有人都惊讶的是，它或多或少就这么停止了。大约花了一周时间。然后所有这些侵入性的记忆和对事故的强烈重播就这么简单地停止了。他对此感到困惑。在某种程度上，他的困惑似乎呼应了Julia母亲的担忧。换句话说，Jed的情况相对较好，但他发现自己在问为什么他没有变得更糟？是的。他想知道，用他自己的话来说，“为什么我表现得还可以？”他说，这真的是我的问题。为什么我表现得还可以？他之前已经
taken psychology classes before this accident, but he went back and finished his master's degree, and then he ended up getting a PhD in clinical psychology. Actually, he came to work with me, which is how I know him, and he's now a professor of clinical psychology in a university. George was surprised by his own reaction to his father's death. He expected tears, but felt only a deep silence. Julia's mother was worried she moved on too quickly from the loss of her father and that she was not grieving properly.
在事故前上过心理学课程，但他回去完成了硕士学位，然后最终获得了临床心理学博士学位。实际上，他后来和我一起工作，这就是我认识他的原因，他现在是一所大学的临床心理学教授。George对自己父亲去世后的反应感到惊讶。他以为自己会流泪，却只感到一种深深的沉默。Julia的母亲担心她从父亲去世的阴影中走出来太快，认为她没有适当地悲伤。
And Jed was surprised he was less traumatized than he ought to have been. Are these three people merely aberrations from the way most people respond to grief, disaster, and tragedy? When we come back, George begins to systematically study what happens to people after they suffer major setbacks. The answer surprised him. It may surprise you too. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantham. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanth. Many of us know how people are supposed to behave after suffering a major loss or personal setback. The loss of a beloved friend, spending extended time in a war zone, going through a natural disaster,
而Jed对自己受到的创伤比预期的要小感到惊讶。这三个人仅仅是大多数人应对悲伤、灾难和悲剧方式的偏差吗？当我们回来时，George将开始系统地研究人们在遭受重大挫折后会发生什么。答案让他感到惊讶。它可能也会让你感到惊讶。你正在收听的是Hidden Brain。我是Shankar Vedantam。这里是Hidden Brain。我是Shankar Vedantam。我们许多人都知道人们在遭受重大损失或个人挫折后应该表现出什么样子。失去挚友、在战区待了很长时间、经历自然灾害，
all these stretch the limits of the human mind and bend us to a true. trauma. Spend a moment on YouTube or TikTok, and you will see many accounts of how trauma is supposed to affect the human mind. Three ways that childhood trauma shows up in adulthood. Did you catch this profound insight into trauma from Enkanta? People with a history of trauma have something called a paralysis of initiation. They're not self-starters.
所有这些都拉伸了人类心灵的极限，并让我们屈服于创伤。在YouTube或TikTok上花点时间，你会看到许多关于创伤应该如何影响人类心灵的叙述。“童年创伤在成年期表现出来的三种方式。”“你捕捉到《魔法满屋》中关于创伤的深刻见解了吗？”“有创伤史的人有一种所谓的‘启动瘫痪’。他们不是主动型的人。”
You realize that everybody's personality is literally just a trauma response. That highly ambitious motivated person, trauma response, that people pleaser who's so nice to Everybody, trauma response, the types of people you're attracted to, trauma response. At Columbia University, George Bonano studies how people respond to setbacks and disaster. One telling moment came after the 9-11 terrorist attacks in New York. Experts were very sure about what would happen in the aftermath of the horrific attacks. The general consensus really was that this. This was going to be a mental health crisis of unprecedented proportions.
“你意识到每个人的性格实际上都只是创伤反应吗？那个雄心勃勃、积极进取的人，是创伤反应；那个对每个人都很好、讨好型的人，是创伤反应；你被吸引的人的类型，是创伤反应。”在哥伦比亚大学，George Bonano研究人们如何应对挫折和灾难。一个具有启发性的时刻出现在9-11恐怖袭击之后。专家们非常确定袭击发生后会发生什么。普遍的共识确实是，这将是一场前所未有的心理健康危机。
People were basically arguing that there were simply not enough resources for the kind of mental health problems that were coming. And famously, FEMA, the Federal Emergency Management Agency, allocated, I believe, about $130 million, which at the time was a lot more than it is now, for emergency funds in New York, mostly to provide free therapy for New Yorkers. So there was this, you know, overarching belief that this is going to completely overwhelm the population. We're going to be basically a city of traumatized people. And early research did seem to confirm that there was widespread distress.
人们基本上在争论，即将到来的心理健康问题将导致资源严重不足。众所周知，联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）拨出了大约1.3亿美元（在当时这比现在多得多）作为纽约的紧急资金，主要用于为纽约人提供免费治疗。因此，当时有一种压倒性的信念，认为这将完全压垮民众。我们基本上会成为一个充满创伤的人的城市。早期的研究似乎确实证实了存在广泛的痛苦。
Even, you know, sitting in Washington, D.C., I was a reporter at the Washington Post at the time. I still remember sitting on the edge of my bed one evening a couple of weeks after 9-11, and I remember wondering if I would ever feel better. So the effects of this were real, and they affected a lot of people. not just in New York, but around the country. Yes, and actually I think it affected people around the country in some ways even more because there were no cues that this had happened in the past. I vividly remember, you know, I was having nightmares about planes crashing
甚至，你知道，坐在华盛顿特区，我当时是《华盛顿邮报》的记者。我仍然记得9-11发生几周后的一个晚上，我坐在床边，想知道自己是否还能好起来。所以这些影响是真实的，它们影响了很多人，不仅是在纽约，而且在全国各地。是的，实际上我认为它在某些方面对全国人民的影响更大，因为过去没有任何关于此类事件发生的线索。我生动地记得，你知道，我当时做着关于飞机坠毁的噩梦，
where I lived in New York City. It was a lot of uncertainty and uncertainty makes people uneasy. There were reports in the New England Journal of Medicine that 7.5% of Manhattan residents met criteria, met criteria for post-traumatic stress disorder or PTSD, and that proportion rose to 20% for those in lower Manhattan who were close to the World Trade Center and maybe 30% for people directly affected by the attacks. So the numbers were incredibly high in terms of the expectations and the predictions right after the attacks took place. So initially it looked like,
就在我居住的纽约市。当时有很多不确定性，而不确定性让人感到不安。《新英格兰医学杂志》有报道称，7.5%的曼哈顿居民符合创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的标准，对于那些靠近世贸中心、身处曼哈顿下城的居民，这一比例上升到了20%，对于直接受袭击影响的人，这一比例可能高达30%。因此，在袭击发生后的预期和预测中，这些数字高得惊人。所以起初看起来，
I wouldn't say it looked like an unprecedented epidemic even at that point, though, because those numbers are not that different from other kinds of major stressors. But they were high. Yes, they were very high. So researchers continue to survey New Yorkers in the months and years following 9-11. What did they find, George? Well, the numbers dropped precipitously, and by six months, they were more or less back to normal. They were quite low by six months for the city on the whole. How did researchers respond to this?
我不会说在那时它看起来像是一场前所未有的流行病，因为这些数字与其他类型的重大压力源并没有太大区别。但它们确实很高。是的，它们非常高。因此，研究人员在9-11之后的几个月和几年里继续调查纽约人。他们发现了什么，George？嗯，数字急剧下降，到六个月时，它们或多或少恢复了正常。总的来说，六个月后，该市的数字相当低。研究人员是如何回应的？
In some ways, what happened was at odds with the predictions that people had made? Yeah. I would say there was a little bit of denial about this. There were a lot of mental health professionals and researchers who simply didn't focus on that so much. And there was no shortage of psychological casualties because of the number of people involved. So they were focusing on that. But some mental health researchers argued that basically this indicated that we were wrong about our prognoses, that this was people were upset, but being upset at something of that magnitude. is actually what you would expect. And so being upset for a while, especially when the damage reverberated through the city for some time because it damaged infrastructure, it required rethinking many things,
在某种程度上，发生的事情与人们的预测不符？是的。我想人们对此有一点否认。有很多心理健康专业人士和研究人员根本没有过多关注这一点。由于涉及的人数众多，心理创伤病例并不缺乏。所以他们专注于此。但一些心理健康研究人员认为，这基本上表明我们对预后的判断是错误的，人们感到不安，但对那种规模的事情感到不安，
that was actually quite normative. And that was what dissipated. So we mistook that kind of emotional, intense reaction as psychopathology. The PTSD researcher Patricia Resick, famously said, strong emotions do not equal psychopathology, which is the same idea that you're talking about just now. Yes, yes, yes. She was actually, I think, had said that very strongly. So a similar shock to the system came 20 years after 9-11, this time in the form of the COVID pandemic. And this, of course, affected not just the entire country, but the entire world.
实际上正是你所预期的。所以感到不安一段时间，特别是当破坏在城市中回荡了一段时间后，因为它破坏了基础设施，需要重新思考许多事情，这实际上是相当规范的。而这就是消散的东西。所以我们误把那种强烈的情绪反应当作了精神病理学。PTSD研究员Patricia Resick曾有名言：“强烈的情绪并不等于精神病理学”，这和你刚才谈到的观点是一样的。是的，是的，是的。我想她确实非常强烈地表达过这一点。所以，在9-11事件20年后，系统再次受到了类似的冲击，这次是以新冠疫情的形式。当然，这不仅影响了整个国家，也影响了整个世界。
And the illness and death caused by the pandemic, as well as the disruption caused by schools and workplaces shutting down, were expected to have significant effects on people's mental health. What were the predictions this time? And were those predictions born out? Again, there was a prognosis of overwhelming mental health problems that overwhelm the system. This was going to, again, be a problem of such magnitude that the mental health resources we currently had would not be able to handle it. And many mental health experts were assuming we need to do something to take care of this looming disaster, this looming mental health disaster. And what happened eventually? What happened eventually was that the pandemic did not have
疫情造成的疾病和死亡，以及学校和工作场所关闭造成的混乱，预计会对人们的心理健康产生重大影响。这次的预测是什么？这些预测是否得到了证实？同样，人们预测会出现压倒性的心理健康问题，从而压垮系统。这再次成为一个规模巨大的问题，以至于我们现有的心理健康资源将无法应对。许多心理健康专家认为，我们需要采取行动来应对这场迫在眉睫的灾难，这场迫在眉睫的心理健康灾难。最终发生了什么？最终发生的是，疫情并没有
nearly the psychological impact that people thought it would have. There were a lot of studies done, and I don't know if I can call to mind all of these different kinds of studies, but one of the best examples is suicide. People thought suicides would skyrocket during the pandemic. And in fact, suicides stayed the same or declined globally. In my own research, you know, we tracked people over time and we found that people were as resilient and as healthy as they always had been. And this has been seen also all over the world. George, many people believe that we respond to difficult or traumatic experiences by going through a series of stages.
产生人们认为的那种心理影响。人们做了很多研究，我不知道我是否能想起所有这些不同类型的研究，但最好的例子之一是自杀。人们认为疫情期间自杀率会飙升。事实上，全球自杀率保持不变或有所下降。在我自己的研究中，你知道，我们跟踪了人们一段时间，发现人们和以往一样具有韧性，一样健康。这在世界各地也得到了证实。George，许多人认为我们通过经历一系列阶段来应对困难或创伤性经历。
This idea was popularized by Elizabeth Kubla Ross, who said, we go through denial, followed by anger, followed by bargaining, followed by depression, and finally acceptance. Talk about how this theory has gained widespread traction and whether there's much evidence supporting it in scientific circles. Well, initially the theory, Kubler-Ross had proposed a theory to account for how people face their own death. And there's hardly any data on that, any research on that for obvious reasons. People are not interested in participating in research as they face their own death. But then it got foisted onto how people deal with the loss of a loved one. And she didn't actually
这个想法由伊丽莎白·库伯勒-罗斯（Elizabeth Kubler-Ross）推广，她说，我们经历否认，接着是愤怒，接着是讨价还价，接着是抑郁，最后是接受。谈谈这个理论是如何获得广泛支持的，以及在科学界是否有足够的证据支持它。嗯，最初，库伯勒-罗斯提出的理论是为了解释人们如何面对自己的死亡。由于显而易见的原因，几乎没有任何关于此的数据或研究。人们在面对死亡时对参与研究不感兴趣。但后来它被强加到了人们如何处理失去亲人的问题上。而她实际上并没有
do that. That was really other people that did that, other theorists. And it became very popular. I think the reason that it became popular because it's sort of a roadmap, you know, something like grief has got lots of existential threat involved in it. We don't think about death very much and life and death. And suddenly we've lost somebody. We don't know where they are, what that means. And this theory provided very clear answers. Unfortunately, it's far too neat and tidy to actually be true. And the research has never supported it. There's not really been any evidence that it's actually what people go through. And a lot of research it contradicts it. I understand that one of the tenets of the theory is that you have to go
那样做。那实际上是其他人，其他理论家做的。它变得非常流行。我认为它之所以流行，是因为它像是一张路线图，你知道，像悲伤这样的事情涉及很多生存威胁。我们不太考虑死亡，也不太考虑生与死。突然之间我们失去了某人。我们不知道他们在哪里，这意味着什么。而这个理论提供了非常明确的答案。不幸的是，它太整洁、太有序了，以至于不可能是真的。研究从未支持过它。实际上并没有证据表明人们确实会经历这些。而且很多研究都与它相矛盾。我理解该理论的原则之一是你必须
through each stage in order to get to the next stage. So if you try and skip a stage, you'll end up suffering for a longer period of time. So in some ways, the theory is surprisingly prescriptive, if you will. It says that you have to go through stage one before you get to stage two or stage three comes before stage four. And again, this doesn't quite match the scientific evidence on loss and bereavement, right? It does not match the evidence. at all. You know, many people don't go through any of these experiences. There's a lot of idiosyncrasies to how people cope, how they react to things like the death of a loved one, and this precision, this sort of sequential perfection in a sense, doesn't really accommodate it. And it's ended up,
经历每个阶段才能进入下一个阶段。所以如果你试图跳过一个阶段，你最终会遭受更长时间的痛苦。因此，在某种程度上，这个理论出奇地具有规定性。它说你必须在进入第二阶段之前经历第一阶段，或者第三阶段必须在第四阶段之前。同样，这与关于损失和丧亲之痛的科学证据不太吻合，对吧？它根本不符合证据。你知道，许多人根本不会经历这些体验。人们如何应对、如何对失去亲人等事情做出反应，有很多特质，而这种精确性，这种某种意义上的顺序完美，并不能真正容纳它。它最终，
I think, for all the comfort it might give some people at being a kind of a roadmap, it also causes a lot of harm, because when people don't experience those stages, other people then argue that perhaps there's something wrong with them. They're not doing the grief properly, and they're going to suffer more if they don't straighten up and do the stages in sequence. And in some ways, this matches your own experience. You experienced this deep silence after your dad passed away, which is not really reflected in the stages of grief.
我想，尽管它可能给一些人带来某种路线图式的安慰，但它也造成了很多伤害，因为当人们没有经历这些阶段时，其他人就会争辩说他们可能出了什么问题。他们没有正确地悲伤，如果他们不振作起来并按顺序完成这些阶段，他们会遭受更多的痛苦。在某种程度上，这与你自己的经历相符。你在父亲去世后经历了这种深深的沉默，这并没有真正反映在悲伤的阶段中。
Julia's mom was really upset that she was not grieving enough. Jed was surprised that he was not reacting with trauma. to what had happened to him. And in some ways, all of you were basically saying, here's the model of how we're supposed to respond to something terrible. And what's wrong with me that I'm not fitting this model? Yes, absolutely. I actually recall in my own experience that after my father died,
Julia的母亲真的很生气，因为她悲伤得不够。Jed对自己没有对发生在他身上的事情产生创伤反应感到惊讶。在某种程度上，你们所有人基本上都在说，这是我们应该如何应对可怕事情的模型。而我没有符合这个模型，我出了什么问题？是的，绝对是。我实际上记得在我自己的经历中，父亲去世后，
I returned to Colorado where I was living and went back to work right away. And the people at work kept telling me, you know, you don't have to work. It's okay. You can take some time off. And I think they were worried that I was, you know, inappropriately coming back to work. When it's really all I wanted to do, I wanted to, you know, and it makes sense because when people come back to work, come back to something that's rewarding to them, they're telling
我回到了我居住的科罗拉多州，并立即回去工作。同事们一直告诉我，你知道，你不必工作。没关系。你可以休假。我想他们担心我，你知道，不恰当地回去工作。而这实际上是我唯一想做的事情，我想，你知道，这很有道理，因为当人们回去工作，回到对他们有回报的事情上时，他们是在告诉
themselves and showing themselves, they still have a role in life. They still have an identity that's not lost. You found that there are many trajectories that characterize how people respond to adversity. and loss. One of these patterns is in fact marked by what you call chronic grief. What is this, George? Chronic grief is simply put the inability to get over the loss. We measure it in a very clear ways, you know, having a lot of the kind of symptoms we associate with grieving, but struggling to function, struggling to think, to concentrate, to be close to other people, and it just simply can't get past that. So they're suffering and suffering for months and often years.
自己并向自己展示，他们在生活中仍然有角色。他们仍然拥有一个没有丢失的身份。你发现有许多轨迹可以描述人们如何应对逆境和损失。其中一种模式实际上以你所说的“慢性悲伤”为标志。这是什么，George？慢性悲伤简单来说就是无法从损失中走出来。我们以非常明确的方式衡量它，你知道，有许多我们与悲伤联系在一起的症状，但难以运作，难以思考，难以集中注意力，难以与他人亲近，而且就是无法跨越那道坎。所以他们遭受着痛苦，持续数月甚至数年。
How many people experience this kind of chronic grief, George? Best estimates, I would say, are at the most about 10% and usually less. A second trajectory that you've identified is what you call the recovery pattern. What is the recovery pattern? The recovery pattern is very interesting. It is a pattern that begins with a lot of different. difficulty, struggle, difficulty, high levels of symptoms and distress. And then gradually over the course of a year or two, the symptoms and the distress diminish
有多少人经历这种慢性悲伤，George？最好的估计，我想说最多大约10%，通常更少。你确定的第二个轨迹是你所说的“恢复模式”。什么是恢复模式？恢复模式非常有趣。这是一种以许多不同的
and the person moves back toward their baseline, where they were before. It takes time, but they're steadily getting better. A third pattern that you've noticed is characterized by a delayed onset of symptoms. What do you mean by this? Well, delayed symptoms, first of all, we don't really see that with grief. There is really no evidence for something called delayed grief. We do see this when there's a trauma, a potentially traumatic event, but we don't see the classic idea of delayed PTSD. Classically, it was a thought that people would be functioning just fine, and maybe this would be
困难、挣扎、高水平的症状和痛苦开始的模式。然后在一两年内，症状和痛苦逐渐减轻，人回到了他们的基线，也就是他们之前的状态。这需要时间，但他们正在稳步好转。你注意到的第三种模式是以症状的延迟发作为特征的。你这是什么意思？嗯，延迟症状，首先，我们在悲伤中并没有真正看到这一点。确实没有证据表明存在所谓的“延迟悲伤”。当发生创伤性事件时，我们确实会看到这一点，但我们没有看到经典的“延迟PTSD”概念。经典地，人们认为人们会运作得很好，也许这会
connected to the idea that perhaps they're in denial, and then out of nowhere, they would suddenly develop PTSD. And the same thing was said for grief as well, that people aren't grieving, like Julia, perhaps, her mother might have thought she's going to have a full-blown grief reaction. She's going to take up on her. It's a dwelling inside her as if it's a thing. It's dwelling inside her and is going to come out and grab her and then she's going to really be suffering. But the mind and the body don't work that way. The grief and emotions are not dwelling inside us as things.
与他们处于否认状态的想法联系起来，然后突然之间，他们会突然患上PTSD。悲伤也是如此，人们没有悲伤，就像Julia一样，也许她的母亲可能认为她会产生全面的悲伤反应。它会像一个东西一样潜伏在她体内。它潜伏在她体内，会出来抓住她，然后她会真正遭受痛苦。但心灵和身体不是那样运作的。悲伤和情绪不是作为东西潜伏在我们体内的。
And when we have seen those patterns, they're not quite as dramatic as that. We see with delayed PTSD, for example, people are. struggling, not doing very well, but they're barely getting by, and they get a little bit worse. Their level of distress, their symptoms increase slowly, and they cross a line to where they're now sort of officially really suffering. But they've actually been struggling all along. That's the pattern we see.
当我们看到这些模式时，它们并不像那样戏剧化。例如，我们看到延迟性PTSD，人们在挣扎，表现得不太好，但他们勉强维持，然后他们变得稍微糟糕一点。他们的痛苦程度、症状缓慢增加，他们越过了一条线，现在他们正式地真正遭受痛苦了。但他们实际上一直都在挣扎。这就是我们看到的模式。
You say that the most surprising pattern is also the most common pattern in how people respond to setbacks and tragedy and grief. What is this pattern, George? Well, this pattern, we call the resilience trajectory. Initially, when I began my career, it's very interesting. It was assumed that very few people would show this kind of pattern. They might struggle for a week or two, maybe a little bit longer, have some upheaval in their life that kind of preoccupied. And then that kind of dissipates, and they're more or less functioning normally.
你说最令人惊讶的模式也是人们应对挫折、悲剧和悲伤时最常见的模式。这种模式是什么，George？嗯，这种模式，我们称之为“韧性轨迹”。起初，当我开始我的职业生涯时，这很有趣。人们认为很少有人会表现出这种模式。他们可能会挣扎一两周，也许稍微长一点，生活中有一些让他们全神贯注的动荡。然后那种动荡消散了，他们或多或少正常运作。
We call this a stable trajectory of healthy functioning. And when I first began my career, it was assumed that hardly anybody would show that pattern. And if they did show that pattern, there was something wrong with them. That was the denial idea. When we began to actually look, as what I did in my research, which was the only novel thing about this research, was that we just looked and measured the range of possible responses to see how many people were showing these responses. When we actually did that, we found that the majority, it's almost always the majority
我们称之为“健康运作的稳定轨迹”。当我刚开始职业生涯时，人们认为几乎没有人会表现出这种模式。如果他们表现出这种模式，他们一定出了什么问题。那就是“否认”的想法。当我们开始真正观察时，就像我在研究中所做的那样，这是这项研究中唯一新颖的地方，我们只是观察并测量了可能的反应范围，看看有多少人表现出这些反应。当我们真正这样做时，我们发现大多数人，几乎总是大多数人
that's showing that pattern. Most people experience short-term distress, upheaval, and then they continue to function normally after that. It's not that they don't care. It's not that they're not saddened or upset by the event, but they move on with their lives. Do we see these different patterns in all manner of setbacks, people getting divorced, people suffering physical losses,
表现出这种模式。大多数人经历短期的痛苦、动荡，然后在此之后继续正常运作。并不是说他们不在乎。并不是说他们没有因为这件事而感到悲伤或难过，但他们继续他们的生活。我们在各种挫折中都能看到这些不同的模式吗？人们离婚、遭受身体损失、
people with injuries or ailments, people losing a loved one? Do we see these different patterns of response for all manner of different setbacks, George? Yes, absolutely. We've now done this. My team has done a lot of this, but other research teams are also doing this. We've seen these patterns in now about 100 different studies, actually, for everything from the worst kinds of events like, you know, traumatic injury, mass shooting, spinal cord injury, to things that are, you know, like loss and relationships. divorce, we've seen it for financial problems, losing a job, etc. So it's the range of
有伤病或疾病的人、失去亲人的人？我们能看到所有不同挫折的这些不同反应模式吗，George？是的，绝对可以。我们现在已经做到了。我的团队做了很多这样的研究，但其他研究团队也在做。我们现在已经在大约100项不同的研究中看到了这些模式，实际上，从最糟糕的事件，比如创伤性伤害、大规模枪击、脊髓损伤，到像关系损失、离婚这样的事情，我们已经看到了它，我们已经看到了财务问题、失业等等。所以这就是范围。
anything that's sort of a serious event that somebody's going to go through that's going to upheave them, cause upheaval in their life for a while. We'll see these same patterns. I want to spend a few moments talking about why the popular understanding of loss and grief has come to be at odds with what the scientific data is showing. How do people respond when you share your findings about resilience with them, George? Well, I've been doing this for a long time, Shankar. I've been doing this for about 35 years now. So initially, it was difficult.
任何一个人经历的某种严重事件，都会在一段时间内给他们的生活带来动荡。我们会看到同样的模式。我想花点时间谈谈，为什么大众对丧亲和悲伤的理解会与科学数据所显示的结果相抵触。乔治，当你与他人分享你的韧性研究发现时，人们有什么反应？嗯，我做这项研究已经很长时间了，尚卡尔。我已经做了大约35年了。所以起初，这很困难。
We began to report these findings in scientific journals, and they were more or less ignored. And I was young, and I'm told that I had kind of an extremely young face. So it was easy to dismiss, this is just some young guy doing this research. But over time, as we began to pile up the evidence, the negative reactions began to happen. And particularly from the trauma world, people in the trauma world would tell me, you know, you're a good researcher, but there's something wrong about what you're doing. And therapists would come up to me if given a public lecture and tell me, you know,
我们开始在科学期刊上发表这些发现，但它们或多或少被忽视了。那时我很年轻，据说我长了一张极其年轻的脸。所以人们很容易不屑一顾，认为这只是某个年轻人做的研究。但随着时间的推移，当我们开始积累证据时，负面反应就开始出现了。特别是来自创伤领域的人，他们会告诉我，你知道，你是个好研究员，但你所做的事情有些不对劲。如果我在公开演讲，治疗师会走过来告诉我，你知道，
I'm sure you're a good scientist, but you're just wrong about this. It's just wrong. I know, and you're wrong. And that happened for quite some years. I'd say 15, maybe 20 years even, and it's slowed down a bit. But oddly, there's been a revival of this idea in recent years, a revival of the idea that everybody is traumatized. Where do you think that comes from, George? Well, it took me by surprise.
我相信你是个优秀的科学家，但你在这件事上就是错了。这完全是错的。我知道，你错了。这种情况持续了好几年。我想说15年，甚至20年，现在稍微慢了一些。但奇怪的是，近年来这种观点又复兴了，即“每个人都受到创伤”的观点。你认为这源于什么，乔治？嗯，这让我感到惊讶。
I think it's mostly in younger people, probably has something to do with the Internet. I know there are a lot of these cultural phenomenon like on. TikTok, there's something called trauma dumping, where people go on TikTok and tell their trauma stories, and those are very popular sites when people do that. So I don't know really besides that how this has come about, how this has been revived. Now, it's certainly possible, George, that some of the people who come up and disagree with you are, in fact, people who have experienced chronic grief. You told me that about one in ten people do experience long-term trauma from these experiences. So it's perhaps understandable why someone with long-term problems
我认为这主要发生在年轻人身上，可能与互联网有关。我知道有很多这样的文化现象，比如在TikTok上，有一种叫“创伤倾倒”（trauma dumping）的东西，人们在TikTok上讲述他们的创伤故事，当人们这样做时，这些网站非常受欢迎。所以我真的不知道除了这些之外，这种情况是如何产生的，又是如何复苏的。乔治，当然有可能，一些走过来反驳你的人，实际上是那些经历过长期悲伤的人。你告诉我，大约十分之一的人确实会因为这些经历而遭受长期创伤。所以，为什么有长期问题的人
might generalize from their own experiences. But, you know, we don't see this with many other medical conditions. People who have terminal stage for cancer don't say the only form of cancer is metastatic end-stage cancer. In fact, for most medical conditions, if we must have the problem, all of us would want to have the mildest form of the problem. But somehow people seem resistant to the idea of mild grief or grief that passes by quickly. Something about that seems wrong. Yeah, grief, I think, has a different element to it. That element that somehow you are not honoring the person that had died if you move on too quickly. But there's another element to it also, which is that we are wired, if I can use that word, we're wired for threat, for danger.
可能会从他们自己的经历中进行概括，这是可以理解的。但是，你知道，我们在许多其他医疗状况中并没有看到这种情况。患有四期癌症的晚期患者不会说癌症的唯一形式就是转移性终末期癌症。事实上，对于大多数医疗状况，如果我们必须患上这种病，我们所有人都希望患上最轻微的形式。但不知何故，人们似乎抵触轻微悲伤或很快消逝的悲伤这一想法。关于这一点似乎有些不对劲。是的，我认为悲伤有不同的元素。那种认为如果你走得太快，就是对死者不尊重的元素。但还有另一个元素，那就是我们天生——如果我可以用这个词的话——我们天生就是为了应对威胁和危险而设计的。
You know, we pay attention when something bad happens. The Internet knows this, you know, all media know this, the clicks online come from really bad things that are attention-getting things, ugly, disastrous things. In the modern era, just around the time of when the Internet was really taking off, was when also these diagnoses for grief and trauma really came to the fore and lots of books are written about how bad these things can be. And the books were well meant and they were accurate books about the disorder itself
你知道，当坏事发生时，我们会关注。互联网知道这一点，你知道，所有媒体都知道这一点，网上的点击量来自那些真正糟糕的、引人注目的事情，丑陋的、灾难性的事情。在现代，就在互联网真正兴起的时候，这些关于悲伤和创伤的诊断也真正走到了前台，许多书写着这些事情有多么糟糕。这些书是出于好意，而且关于疾病本身的描述也是准确的，
when people can't recover. But those books got a lot of attention. And I think led to the idea in the popular culture that these events are going to really harm us when they happen. I've argued actually that one reason why therapists tend to think that trauma is more common than it is, and therapists do overestimate the prevalence of trauma, typically, is if they see traumatized people, they see traumatized people in their practice, and they see a lot more than is in the normal populations than the base rates. So they tend to then overgeneralize that to the
当人们无法恢复时。但这些书引起了极大的关注。我认为这导致大众文化中产生了一种想法，即这些事件发生时会真正伤害我们。实际上，我曾论证过，治疗师倾向于认为创伤比实际更常见的一个原因——治疗师通常会高估创伤的普遍性——是因为他们看到的是受过创伤的人，他们在实践中看到受过创伤的人，他们看到的比正常人群中的基准率要多得多。所以他们倾向于将其过度概括到
general population. It's a very human thing to do. It's not evil or dumb. It's a very human thing that therapists do, because they are humans. It's also the case that I think after mass tragedies, think about the 9-11 attacks, or if you think about, you know, disasters like the COVID pandemic or a natural disaster, in some ways, if I come and tell you, look, things are going to be really bad. A lot of people are going to be affected. We should do a lot. And it turns out I'm wrong. People will just say, okay, you know, his intentions were in the right place, but he made a mistake. But if I come and tell you after an event like this, you know, most people are going to be fine. You know, even if I turn out to be right, I can come across as callous.
普通人群中。这是一种非常人性化的做法。这并不邪恶或愚蠢。这是治疗师会做的一种非常人性化的事情，因为他们也是人。同样的情况是，我认为在大规模悲剧之后，想想9/11袭击，或者如果你想想，你知道，像新冠疫情或自然灾害这样的灾难，在某种程度上，如果我走过来告诉你，看，事情会变得非常糟糕。很多人会受到影响。我们应该做很多事情。结果证明我错了。人们只会说，好吧，你知道，他的初衷是好的，但他犯了一个错误。但如果我在这样的事件后走过来告诉你，你知道，大多数人都会没事的。你知道，即使我最终证明是对的，我也可能显得冷酷无情。
Yeah. There's something I call. the resilience blind spot, which is that right in the middle of, particularly in a disaster, but when we're in the middle of, in the throes of our initial reaction to a seriously aversive event, you know, we do get upset. We have a very good stress response. Our mind-body system has a very well-honed stress response. It's been honed by millions and millions of years of evolution. And you can't activate that response without first feeling stress. So you have to be upset. in order for that response to kick in. So that initial upset we have tends to blind us to the idea that will ever not feel that way.
是的。我称之为“韧性盲点”，也就是说，正处于灾难之中，特别是当我们处于对严重厌恶事件的初步反应的阵痛中时，你知道，我们确实会感到不安。我们有一个非常好的压力反应。我们的身心系统有一个非常磨练的压力反应。它经过了数百万年进化的磨练。如果不先感到压力，你就无法激活这种反应。所以你必须感到不安，这种反应才能启动。所以我们最初的不安往往会让我们对“我们永远不会再有这种感觉”的想法视而不见。
We have a hard time as humans with that. Our minds have a hard time with that. And when there's a disaster or something large scale, there's a kind of a contagion that happens as well. Other people are upset too. And so they're upset and I should be upset and I am upset and now you're upset. You know, and that kind of happens quite fast. When we come back, how the popular understanding of trauma, even if well-intentioned, can sometimes inadvertently create new forms of suffering. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta.
作为人类，我们很难做到这一点。我们的思想很难做到这一点。当发生灾难或大规模事件时，也会发生一种传染。其他人也很不安。所以他们不安，我也应该不安，我感到不安，现在你也感到不安。你知道，这种情况发生得很快。当我们回来时，我们将讨论大众对创伤的理解，即使是出于好意，有时也会无意中造成新的痛苦形式。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. What are your experiences with grief and tragedy? How have you coped with setbacks in your life? What advice have you shared with others who are dealing with loss? If you have thoughts or questions that you would be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at Ideas at HiddenBrain.org. Use the subject line, trauma. Two or three minutes is plenty.
这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你对悲伤和悲剧有什么经历？你是如何应对生活中的挫折的？你对那些正在处理失落的人分享过什么建议？如果你有愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的想法或问题，请在手机上录制语音备忘录并发送电子邮件至Ideas@HiddenBrain.org。使用主题行：创伤。两三分钟就足够了。
and again, that's ideas at hiddenbrain.org. George Bonano is a psychologist at Teachers College, Columbia University. He is the author of The End of Trauma, how the new science of resilience is changing how we think about PTSD. Some of our conversation today, George, has been about how the work you've done, the scientific findings, are at odds with how our culture says we should respond or ought to respond to setbacks or tragedy
再说一遍，那是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。乔治·博南诺是哥伦比亚大学师范学院的心理学家。他是《创伤的终结：韧性的新科学如何改变我们对创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的看法》一书的作者。乔治，我们今天谈话的一部分是关于你所做的工作、科学发现与我们的文化所说的我们应该如何应对挫折或悲剧的方式之间的矛盾，
or potentially traumatic events. Can you talk about some of the ways in which our culture offers what you might call unhelpful ideas about how we should respond to these events? Yes, I think that there's been a tendency in the last decade in particular of focusing far too much on human frailty, I think, as if people are easily breakable. And there's been a sense of not wanting people to suffer in any way.
或潜在的创伤性事件。你能谈谈我们的文化在应对这些事件的方式上提供的一些你可能称之为“无益的想法”吗？是的，我认为在过去十年中，人们有一种倾向，即过于关注人类的脆弱性，好像人们很容易破碎。而且有一种不想让人们以任何方式受苦的感觉。
There's a Greek concept called eudamonia, which many people might know about, which is the kind of companion to happiness, but it's not happiness in the sense of joy and hedonic pleasure. It's a sense of reward from achieving something, and that isn't always fun. So I think a lot of what's valuable in life requires a little bit of struggle, and there's a tendency right now to avoid any and all signs of that. One implication of this idea, George says, is to not assume that painful and unpleasant life events will lead to prolonged mental suffering. That could be the case, of course, and if it is, it should be taken seriously,
有一个希腊概念叫“幸福”（eudaimonia），许多人可能知道，它是幸福的一种伴侣，但它不是那种快乐和享乐主义意义上的幸福。它是一种从实现某事中获得的奖励感，而这并不总是很有趣。所以我认为生活中许多有价值的东西都需要一点挣扎，而现在有一种避免所有这些迹象的倾向。乔治说，这个想法的一个含义是，不要假设痛苦和不愉快的生活事件会导致长期的精神痛苦。当然，情况可能是这样，如果是这样，就应该认真对待，
and people who are suffering should seek help. But it's not useful to assume that everyone, or even most people, will have prolonged grief or long-term trauma. I've had many experiences like this. I recall once when my children were smaller and there was the preschool they were going to and one of the teachers told me that one of the children's parents had lost a parent over the summer break and she didn't know what to do when the child came back to the class. She asked me if she could talk with me about it and she said, what should I do?
受苦的人应该寻求帮助。但假设每个人，甚至大多数人，都会有长期的悲伤或长期的创伤，是没有用的。我有很多这样的经历。我记得有一次，当我的孩子们还小的时候，他们去的幼儿园里，一位老师告诉我，其中一个孩子的父母在暑假期间失去了一位亲人，当孩子回到班级时，她不知道该怎么办。她问我是否可以和我谈谈，她说，我该怎么办？
And I said, maybe nothing. And she was quite taken aback by that. But the point I made to her was, you know, maybe this child doesn't want a lot of attention call to him. Maybe he wants to just be a normal kid in the class. Let it play out and see what happens. Can you talk a moment about the widespread use of trigger warnings? Many schools and media organizations are worried about the mental health impacts of
我说，也许什么都不做。她对此感到非常吃惊。但我对她说的重点是，你知道，也许这个孩子不想引起太多的关注。也许他只想在班里做一个正常的孩子。让它自然发展，看看会发生什么。你能谈谈关于“触发警告”（trigger warnings）的广泛使用吗？许多学校和媒体机构担心心理健康的影响，
sharing negative information with students, with listeners, with viewers. Do these warnings work? And how do you think they're connected with the conversation we're having about trauma and resilience? Trigger warnings were born out of the idea that everybody's, well, there's a wise but idea that people have hidden traumas lurking inside them or past traumas that were unresolved and they're kind of somehow raw inside people. That's a very common, became a very common assumption. And the trigger warning idea emerged from that as a kind of a way to say, you know, if anybody's
向学生、听众、观众分享负面信息。这些警告有效吗？你认为它们与我们正在进行的关于创伤和韧性的对话有什么联系？触发警告源于这样一种想法，即每个人，嗯，有一个明智但错误的想法，即人们内心潜伏着隐藏的创伤，或者过去未解决的创伤，它们在人们内心深处以某种方式是原始的。这是一个非常普遍的假设，后来成为一个非常普遍的假设。触发警告的想法由此产生，作为一种方式，意思是，你知道，如果这里有任何人
got a trauma here in this room or has a trauma lurking inside them, we're going to show some content here, you're going to experience something if you stay for this presentation that might trigger that. And it was based on the idea that everybody is kind of walking around with these barely below the surface traumas that can explode at any point. And that's really not accurate in any sense of the word. I think we couldn't function as human beings if we were actually built like that. And the research on trigger warnings is shown fairly convincingly that they either don't help or they cause harm. People who are given trigger warnings often are more anxious than people who didn't give trigger warnings, didn't receive them. In research, George
在这个房间里有创伤，或者内心潜伏着创伤，我们将在这里展示一些内容，如果你留下来参加这个演讲，你可能会经历一些可能触发该创伤的事情。它基于这样一种想法，即每个人都带着这些几乎在表面之下的创伤走来走去，这些创伤随时可能爆发。这在任何意义上都不准确。我认为如果我们真的是那样构建的，我们就无法作为人类运作。关于触发警告的研究已经相当令人信服地表明，它们要么没有帮助，要么造成了伤害。收到触发警告的人通常比没有收到触发警告的人更焦虑。在研究中，乔治
has done with former hidden brain guest, Dakor Keltner, he's found that our mistaken beliefs about human fragility cause people to walk on eggshells around those who have suffered losses. In fact, research finds that even people in acute grief can smile and laugh, and smiling and Laughter are correlated with positive long-term mental health. The research shows quite clearly that most people, even people who've recently lost a spouse within the last few months, when we did interviews, we found that the majority of people were showing genuine laughter and smiling during the interview. And that's because these are very social processes.
与《隐藏的大脑》的前嘉宾达科·凯尔特纳（Dakor Keltner）一起做过研究，他发现我们对人类脆弱性的错误信念导致人们在那些遭受损失的人周围如履薄冰。事实上，研究发现，即使是处于急性悲伤中的人也可以微笑和欢笑，而微笑和欢笑与长期的积极心理健康相关。研究非常清楚地表明，大多数人，即使是最近几个月内失去配偶的人，当我们进行采访时，我们发现大多数人在采访中表现出真诚的欢笑和微笑。这是因为这些是非常社会化的过程。
Most of the time when we laugh and smile, almost all the time it's with other people. And they're very pro-social. They're contagious. They connect us to other people. And what we've seen in our research with grief is that people kind of go in and out of these phases. You might see somebody crying and holding their head and, you know, shaking their head because they're so upset. And then 30 seconds later, they're laughing. They're still have tears on their face and they're laughing about something they remembered. And that laughter we posited is
大多数时候我们欢笑和微笑，几乎所有时候都是与其他人在一起。它们非常亲社会。它们具有传染性。它们将我们与其他人联系起来。我们在悲伤研究中看到的是，人们会进出这些阶段。你可能会看到有人哭泣、抱着头，你知道，因为太难过而摇头。然后30秒后，他们就在笑了。他们脸上还有泪水，他们正在谈论他们记得的事情而欢笑。我们假设那种笑声是
laughter is a kind of a way to reconnect with the person and almost reward the person for listening, but also rewarding ourselves, letting us feel connected to somebody else. It's very, very human process. There's been a kind of a prohibition about it for a number of years because somehow it's not respectful or it means you don't care. But in fact, it actually does mean you care enough to live your life. When we start by assuming most people will display resilience in the face of setbacks, George says we can discover new ways to cope. Years after his father's death, George found himself conversing aloud with his dad.
笑声是一种与那个人重新联系的方式，几乎是奖励那个人倾听，但也奖励我们自己，让我们感到与某人联系在一起。这是一个非常非常人性化的过程。多年来，对此有一种禁令，因为不知何故，这不尊重，或者意味着你不关心。但事实上，它确实意味着你关心到足以过好你的生活。乔治说，当我们从假设大多数人在挫折面前会表现出韧性开始时，我们可以发现应对的新方法。在他父亲去世多年后，乔治发现自己在大声与父亲交谈。
Someone who was watching him might have thought that longstanding, unresolved traumas were rearing their head. George says it was just the opposite. He was developing a relationship with his father that he did not have while his father was alive. What I had done in my own life was I began to talk with my father. And I would talk with him. And this is primarily when I had my own children. And so I was now a father. And being a father, being a parent is not easy.
看着他的人可能会认为长期的、未解决的创伤正在抬头。乔治说，事实恰恰相反。他正在与父亲建立一种父亲在世时没有的关系。我在自己的生活中所做的是，我开始与父亲交谈。我会和他说话。这主要是在我有了自己的孩子之后。所以我现在是一位父亲。作为一名父亲，作为一名父母并不容易。
And there were times when I just thought I wish that my father was alive, despite the difficulties we had when he was alive, I felt this would be different now. I'm a different person. He would undoubtedly be a different person as well. And so I began to talk with him in the elevator in my building. I live in an old building in New York. And the elevator is quite slow. So I felt safe in the elevator because nobody would see me.
有时我只是想，我希望我的父亲还活着，尽管我们在他活着时有困难，但我感到现在情况会不同了。我是一个不同的人。他无疑也会是一个不同的人。所以我开始在我的大楼电梯里和他说话。我住在纽约的一栋老楼里。电梯很慢。所以我感到在电梯里很安全，因为没有人会看到我。
And I knew when that door was going to open. because the elevator would stop slowly and there was a pause before the door open. So I began to talk with my father. And I found this very comforting. They have these conversations with him. I'm wondering what you asked your father, George, and whether he said anything in response?
我知道门什么时候会打开，因为电梯会慢慢停下来，在门打开之前有一个停顿。所以我开始和父亲说话。我发现这非常令人安慰。他们与他进行这些对话。我想知道你问了你父亲什么，乔治，他有没有回应什么？
You know, I might be asking about, you know, one of my children or, you know, how having children changes the way you think or, you know, I was noticing things say, I would have been much more carefree until I became a parent. and I was worrying about money, and I would say something, you know, Dad, I know you are very concerned about money.
你知道，我可能会问关于，你知道，我的一个孩子，或者，你知道，有孩子如何改变你的思维方式，或者，你知道，我注意到了一些事情，比如，在成为父母之前，我会更无忧无虑。而我当时在担心钱，我会说一些话，你知道，爸爸，我知道你非常关心钱。
You know, this is really hard, you know, and I would really just talk with him about it. You know, obviously he'd never answered back. But, you know, it was more like I would imagine how he was responding and just be able to tell him this. There is a great deal of variability in how people respond to difficult life events. What causes one person to suffer endlessly after a loss or setback while others bounce back? What are the drivers of human resilience?
你知道，这真的很难，你知道，我会真的只是和他谈论这件事。你知道，显然他从来没有回答过。但是，你知道，这更像是我会想象他是如何回应的，并且能够告诉他这些。人们对困难生活事件的反应存在很大的差异。是什么导致一个人在失落或挫折后无休止地受苦，而另一些人却能反弹？人类韧性的驱动力是什么？
For a long time, researchers have wrestled with the question. Many different factors, like courage or patience or social ties, can shape whether we are resilient. But George Bonano has found that there is one central orientation that is absolutely crucial. It's a matter of really working out what is the right situation? What is the right way to behave in this situation? What's the right way to cope in that situation?
长期以来，研究人员一直在纠结这个问题。许多不同的因素，如勇气、耐心或社会关系，可以塑造我们是否具有韧性。但乔治·博南诺发现，有一种核心取向是绝对关键的。这是一个真正弄清楚什么是正确情况的问题。什么是应对这种情况的正确方式？什么是应对那种情况的正确方式？
And that led me to this idea of what we call behavioral flexibility. It's a set of skills that we see in people that solve this problem. What do I need to do now? What's the problem I'm facing now and what do I need to do about it? What can I do about it? We talk about this idea in our companion story on Hidden Brain Plus. It's titled
这引导我产生了我们所说的“行为灵活性”的想法。这是一套我们在人们身上看到的解决这个问题的技能。我现在需要做什么？我现在面临的问题是什么，我需要对此做什么？我能对此做什么？我们在《隐藏的大脑Plus》的配套故事中讨论了这个想法。它的标题是
How to Be More Resilient. If you're a subscriber, that episode should be available right now in your podcast feed. If not, I would love for you to sign up at support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.com slash hidden brain.
如何变得更有韧性。如果你是订阅者，该剧集现在应该可以在你的播客订阅源中找到。如果没有，我很乐意你在support.hiddenbrain.org注册。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问apple.com/hiddenbrain。
You'll have access to a free one-week trial in both places and your support will go a long way to helping us build a show. Again, that's support. dot hiddenbrain.org and apple.com slash hidden brain. George Bonano is a psychologist at Teachers College Columbia University. He is the author of The End of Trauma,
你将在两个地方获得为期一周的免费试用，你的支持将对我们建立这个节目大有帮助。再说一遍，那是support.hiddenbrain.org和apple.com/hiddenbrain。乔治·博南诺是哥伦比亚大学师范学院的心理学家。他是《创伤的终结》的作者，
how the new science of resilience is changing how we think about PTSD, and the other side of sadness, what the new science of bereavement tells us about life after loss. George, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been absolutely my pleasure, Shankar. Have you had experiences with tragedy that match or contradict the ideas you've heard on the show today? Have you experienced difficulty aligning
韧性的新科学如何改变我们对PTSD的看法，以及《悲伤的另一面：丧亲的新科学告诉我们关于失落后的生活》。乔治，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。这绝对是我的荣幸，尚卡尔。你是否有过与你在节目中听到的想法相符或矛盾的悲剧经历？你是否经历过难以协调
how you felt about a terrible life event with how those around you expected you to behave? If you have thoughts or questions for George Bonanno that you would be willing to share with a hidden brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, trauma. Two or three minutes is plenty.
你对一件可怕的生活事件的感受与周围人期望你的行为方式之间的矛盾？如果你有愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的想法或问题，请在手机上录制语音备忘录并发送电子邮件至Ideas@HiddenBrain.org。使用主题行：创伤。两三分钟就足够了。
Again, that's Ideas at Hidden Brain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. I'm Shankar Vedantham. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再说一遍，那是Ideas@HiddenBrain.org。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。